[Música]
economía en directo américa de france 24
han generando nuevamente en el estudio
danny la cumbre de líderes en bruselas
hoy es económica sí señor raúl pues
comenzaron en bruselas la segunda
jornada de su cumbre dedicada en
especial esta vez a valorar la situación
económica y con el ojo puesto también en
la inflación el canciller alemán olaf
scholz dijo que la seguridad energética
es uno de los temas clave del encuentro
que podemos ver se está realizando en
este momento al respecto y también sobre
la inflación se refirieron varios
líderes antes de que iniciara esta
jornada
sólo hay una forma de superarlo y es
todos juntos debemos formar un bloque
energético si lo hacemos por separado
nos hundiremos todos por separado por lo
que ahora la comisión europea tiene que
asegurarse de comprar energía como grupo
de usar un límite de precio y de
planificar puntos para superar el
invierno
lo que parece una solución fácil es que
los gobiernos pongan más dinero en los
bolsillos de los ciudadanos pero cuando
la inflación se da por la escasez de
suministros esto no solucionará el
problema solo aumentará la inflación así
que lo que parece una solución fácil en
realidad no lo es y eso es lo que
tenemos que discutir y también ser
honestos con los ciudadanos europeos
daniela y yo que quería un toyota pues
parece que estoy cambiando de opinión
porque nadie quisiera un carro sin
llantas no el primer vehículo eléctrico
fabricado a gran escala por toyota no es
el todo seguro o con llantas defectuosas
raúl yo también quería un toyota de
pérez mejor de esla sí señor la
multinacional japonesa llamó a retirar
del mercado dos mil 700 vehículos
crossover de la referencia
a 4x ustedes lo van a ver en pantalla
raúl este modelo mide lo que usted ve
acá oracular es su primer auto
totalmente eléctrico fabricado en masa
lanzado hace apenas dos meses pero según
la empresa existe un riesgo de que las
ruedas se aflojen por lo que hasta tanto
no esté solucionado este problema nadie
que los haya adquirido puede conducir
estos vehículos por si lo adquirió la
mayoría de los autos está en europa
américa latina américa del norte no
latina y asia el mercado no demora en
cobrarle la equivocación a la compañía
su acción cayó más del 1 por ciento en
la bolsa ya que esta noticia es un revés
para las ambiciones del que hoy en día
es el mayor vendedor de autos del mundo
de electrificar su gama de modelos ahora
otra noticia también relacionada
raúl es que subaru que es otra
fabricante la que toyota tiene una
participación de casi el 20 por ciento
también está retirando del mercado unas
2.600 unidades de su modelo solterra que
también es su primer vehículo totalmente
eléctrico y comparte componentes
principales con este modelo también el
z4 x tocaba manejarlo con los
picapiedras quienes solo
dan y las autoridades eeuu ordenaron la
suspensión de las ventas a un gigante
del mapeo se trata de la compañía you'll
los reguladores habían ordenado a las
empresas de mapeo que demostrarán que
sus productos eran un beneficio para la
salud pública básicamente que ayudarán a
los fumadores adultos a dejar de hacerlo
oa reducir su consumo algunas compañías
sí lo hicieron efectivamente pero
después de una revisión de dos años la
jefe de a que la autoridad regulatoria
dijo que julie no los había convencido y
le ordenó retirar todos sus productos
del mercado a julen se le acusa de haber
elevado el consumo entre adolescentes
por vender bateadores con sabor a frutas
y dulces que dejó de comercializar en
2019 por orden de las autoridades
también y se dedicó a sabores como
tabaco y mentol ellos han insistido que
ofrecen una alternativa más saludable a
los cigarrillos tradicionales y van a
apelar la decisión bueno mejor que a
pasar indicadores las acciones asiáticas
se cerraron en positivo siguiendo la
buena jornada previa de wollscheid que
se encamina a su primera ganancia
semanal en tres semanas europa opera al
alza media jornada con un mercado que
espera ansioso el dato de inflación de
eeuu que sale la próxima semana cifra el
día raúl está en argentina el instituto
de estadística reveló que su economía
creció 6% interanual en el primer
trimestre de 2020 con lo que acumula
cinco trimestres consecutivos de
crecimiento pero se ha venido
desacelerando también dio a conocer que
el desempleo se mantuvo en 7% en el
mismo período es decir hay casi un
millón de personas sin trabajo en este
país en el que no obstante reina la
informalidad danny como siempre gracias
por toda la información económica ya no
fuimos a londres a no nos vamos hasta
hasta parís